toutes et tous nous avons une certaine
vision de la réalité qui nous entoure
cette manière de voir les objets de
notre quotidien et partage et
socialement notre entourage
notre famille et nos amis ont souvent
une vision très proche d'autres
individus dans d'autres groupes à
d'autres époques ou dans d'autres
cultures auront une autre vision
concurrente à la nôtre par exemple
l'école est perçu par certains
certaines comme un espace de
socialisation d'autres un lieu de
transmission et d'apprentissage une
partie considère comme un espace de
confrontation voire de torture nous
avons donc une appartenance sociale qui
va façonner notre manière de considérer
l'école et ses manières seront plus ou
moins proche de celle des autres
personnes en sciences sociales ses
manières de voir les choses sont appelés
les représentations sociales
je m'appelle sylvain draps mais je suis
professeur de sciences sociales dans le
secondaire supérieur en belgique qui
vient de belgique est voix et dans cette
vidéo je vous explique ce que sont les
caractéristiques et les fonctions de
représentation sociale une
représentation sociale est une
construction intellectuelle collective
qui donne du sens au monde qui nous
entoure dans lequel nous vivons et qui
nous permet d'agir sur celui ci dans
celui ci j'y vois des représentations
partout ces représentations sont un mode
de connaissance pratique du réel qui se
pose par exemple la connaissance
scientifique
les représentations sont donc un concept
très important des sciences sociales et
en particulier de la psychologie sociale
en effet nos représentations sont à la
base de la quasi majorité de nos actions
et de nos pensées
elles sont le moteur de nos
comportements les représentations
sociales ne sont pas des opinions qui
sont beaucoup plus individuelle et moins
stable et représentation étant donné
qu'elles sont construites et partagée
par les membres d'un même groupe voire
d'une même société sont plus stables
plus intériorisée que des opinions qui
sont plus individuelle et plus
conscientisés les artésiens comme elles
sont partagées par les membres d'un même
groupe d'une même catégorie sociale
voire d'une même société
on dit qu'elles sont sociales étant
donné que les personnes que l'on comtois
et qui participe à notre socialisation
font partie du ou des mêmes groupes et
de la même société nos représentations
nous apparaissent évidentes et naturel
on dirait qu'elles sont
native elles définissent une norme de
plus comme elles dépendent des groupes
et des sociétés auxquelles les individus
appartiennent elles sont toujours
relative on est dit les représentations
sociales sont construites à partir d'une
partie seulement des éléments de la
réalité indications partielles
inconsciemment nous excluons les faits
qui ne correspondent pas à nos
représentations et nous ne retenons que
les éléments qui les confirment elles
résistent donc assez bien aux
apprentissages même si elles sont
contredites par des faits totalement
objectivables les groupes sociaux les
catégories sociales et les sociétés ne
sélectionne pas forcément les mêmes
éléments pour construire leurs
représentations ont dit qu'elles sont
partiales n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
quoi l'auberge
globalement les représentations sociales
nous permettent d'interagir et d'agir
avec les autres à moindre coût cognitif
c'est à dire rapidement et facilement de
manière détaillée nous retiendrons
quatre fonctions remplies par les
représentations sociales par leur
fonction de savoir les représentations
nous permettent de comprendre et
d'expliquer la réalité les
représentations sociales donne du sens
au réel et aux expériences que nous
vivons elles permettent entre autres de
créer des catégories de conceptualiser
de manière spontanée afin de pouvoir
lire le réel par exemple certains
groupes peuvent se représenter
l'économie comme un gâteau à se partager
dès lors l'arrivée d'immigrés dans une
économie peut être à l'origine
d'opinions négatives à leur égard parce
qu'elles sont construites sur cette
représentation de l'économie comme un
gâteau si vous rencontrez une personne
couchée sur le sol dans une tenue
négligée vos représentations vous
conduiront peut-être à considérer qu'il
s'agit d'une personne sans domicile fixe
assoupi ou ivre morte et la situation
vous semblera normal si l'on peut dire
vous trouverez du sens à cette réalité
par contre vous serez un peu perplexe si
une personne très soignée en tailleur ou
complet trois pièces est dans la même
position dans ce cas vos représentations
ne vous conduiront pas à penser que la
personne est assoupi ivre et vous en
conclurez qu'elle est peut être victime
d'un malaise
à gauche une jeune fille bien vêtu
simule un malaise à l'arrêt du tram à
droite
une autre étudiante habillé en sd à
gauche la jeune fille bien les tuer
secouru par un passant
en moins de dix secondes alors qu'à
droite personne n'intervient certains
changent de trottoir où passent à
quelques mètres sans regarder le jeune
homme assis juste à côté détourne le
regard
il faudra plus d'une minute trente pour
qu'un témoin s'inquiète de la situation
les représentations sociales font partie
d'un ensemble d'éléments qui participent
à l'existence d'une identité commune et
d'une conscience collective
c'est la fonction d'identité par exemple
les élèves d'une même classe se
représente l'école et certains profs
d'une certaine manière il prouve qu'ils
ne fabriquent
peut-être qu'ils partagent des
plaisanteries sur eux alors qu'ils
clament élèves qui travaillent toi que
d'autres ne comprendraient pas cela
renforce la cohésion du groupe et
participe à la construction d'une
identité commune du groupe class la
fonction d'orientation est un système
d'anticipation des attentes
les représentations sociales permettent
de supposer ce qui va se passer et donc
d'agir en conséquence
elle oriente nos actions par exemple
quand des amis proposent d'aller boire
un verre ou d'aller faire du shopping du
super six qui tue on a une bonne idée du
type d'activité jusque dans ses détails
comme les lieux dans lequel on va se
rendre la durée d'activité l'attitude à
adopter la tenue vestimentaire à
respecter cela est permis par une
représentation commune aux groupes
d'amis de ce qu'est boire un verre ou
faire du shopping
de ce fait les représentations
permettent aussi de communiquer
facilement et d'agir collectivement les
représentations interviennent donc avant
l'action elles peuvent aussi intervenir
après l'action
il s'agit alors de la fonction de
justification la fonction de
justification permet à l'individu de
légitimer c'est à dire rendre acceptable
ses décisions ses actions ses conduites
à l'égard de ses pairs mais aussi envers
d'autres groupes sociaux dans certaines
régions les habitations sont toujours
fermées à clé ah non moi je laisse pas
maintenant tout hairtech tous les
malades qui traînent ici dans la rue
dont d'autres comme dans certaines
régions des pays bas les personnes
n'hésitent pas à laisser leurs portes
ouvertes ici cette différence de
pratiques s'explique en partie par des
représentations différentes du voisinage
d'un côté il est perçu comme hostile et
pas de l'autre un autre exemple est le
maintien de l'ouverture des écoles lors
de la crise sanitaire
c'est parce qu'elles apparaissent comme
des lieux de socialisation et
d'apprentissage à la grande majorité que
les politiques ont justifié leur
décision sur cette base
frire les écoles mais sympa non il
arrive que les élèves rencontrent des
difficultés à bien distinguer les
différentes fonctions non justification
savoir cela est tout à fait normal car
ces différentes fonctions sont liées les
unes aux autres
elles sont parfois difficilement
discernables étant donné qu'elles sont
très très imbriquées cette vidéo est
terminée je vous invite à consulter le
descriptif pour plus de ressources comme
la fiche de cours et toutes les
références qui ont été à la base de cet
exposé je vous invite à vous abonner si
vous avez apprécié cette vidéo je vous
souhaite beaucoup de joie et de plaisir
dans la découverte des sciences sociales
et je vous dis à très bientôt
dans une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]